- [Narrator] Remember
Zoltar, the fortune teller
from the movie Big?
The mysterious machine turned
a young boy’s wish into reality.
In real life there are hundreds
of Zoltars all over the country.
And you can trace them
all back to this guy.
- My name is Olaf Stanton
and I make Zoltar.
(magical harp)
- [Narrator] Olaf runs
Characters Unlimited,
a company that makes
animated talking characters.
And one of those machines,
is a fortune teller.
- The fortune teller is probably
one of the oldest games there is.
It's been around since
the turn of the century.
- [Narrator] Perhaps the
most famous one is Zoltar.
But, just to be clear, they didn't make
the one from the movie Big.
- The Zoltar in the movie Big
was basically a movie prop,
it was never made to
be a manufactured game.
Our Zoltar has the talking
- [Zoltar] Come let Zoltar tell you more!
- and eye movement and head turning,
and spits out a card at
the end of the conversation
and gives you some good words of advice.
- [Narrator] Every Zoltar
machine is custom made.
- The first thing we do is
get the cabinet started,
then we'll cast the head
out of our latex material.
We put the eyeballs in, we paint the head,
then it goes to our wig department.
Zoltar's goatee is put
on, the teeth are put in,
which are actually my teeth.
- [Narrator] Wait, they're your teeth?
- Yes, they're actually my teeth.
I actually made a mold on my teeth,
so every Zoltar you see out
there has my teeth in ‘em.
And then we put all the components in that
make the card come out, and make it talk
and give the different messages.
And then Zoltar's ready to go.
Although Zoltar is the star
of our fortune teller line,
he's not the only fortune
teller that we make.
We have Pappy, we have the old pirate.
- [Narrator] And those
fortunes, that's Olaf too.
- We try to make all of our fortunes
on the lighter side, good
words of wisdom and advice.
I think one of my favorite is, “Sometimes
it's better to say too little than to
say too much and regret it later.”
There’s a lot of good words of wisdom
that come out of Zoltar.
I think people just like to see
something that they can relate to
and say, oh yeah how did you
know that, that's so cool.
It really does bring out
the child in all of us
to see your fortune on a card.
- [Narrator] Unless of course you're
talking about Tom Hanks in the movie Big,
'cause he gets well, ya know, Big.